scary movie five
more like stupid movie five
get it this scary movie was by far the
worst
scary movie that was ever made i
probably laughed in total
four times and that's me being generous
and all those laughs were practically in
the first 30 minutes
so the film first gives you a smidgen of
hope but then the anal [ __ ] you
by taking away that hope simon rex
is likable but he gets very annoying
actually tisdale
is attractive but her performance is
certainly no anna ferris
this film is loaded with celebrity
cameos that
do not do anything for this movie you
would think after a seven year absence
they know not to amplify what already
did not work in the franchise
but no they're [ __ ] idiots they
should have been creative enough to make
a better franchise
for [ __ ] sake they had seven years
what were they thinking
this movie is annoying often boring
limited on laughs
just one big pile of [ __ ] more like
shitty movie five
the comedy balls just keep coming my way
and i keep knocking them out the park
it's one of those movies where the
writers probably thought what they were
doing was funny but is only funny on
paper
and not when it translates to the actual
film let me get straight to the point
here
all in all i gotta say scary movie 5
sucks the biggest
the fattest the most disgusting and
hairiest
balls and it got it wrong
all right ladies and gentlemen thanks
for checking out my video i really
appreciate it
so much that i actually would like you
to subscribe
to my video please go ahead and click on
the link right here to subscribe so you
can get updated every time a new review
is out and on top of that too if you
want to check out a more in-depth review
of one of the biggest pieces of [ __ ] so
far scary movie five go ahead and click
on the link right here to my show called
reasons to see we'll give you reasons
not to see scary movie five thanks for
watching